for the first time in history NASA wants
to hand off routine International Space
Station resupply missions to private
companies though there's way more at
stake than just food and equipment these
space taxi companies hope to transport
Ashland soon and after that tourists so
here's the situation these four
companies you see right here including
Elon Musk SpaceX our building spacecraft
ferry NASA supplies or astronauts to
space and we have liftoff of SpaceX
Falcon 9 rocket and dragon to make space
tourism realistic the price of these
trips needs to come down space
entrepreneurs are counting on two words
to cut costs reusable rockets until now
booster rocket simply burned up upon
reentering the Earth's atmosphere musk
says creating booster rockets that real
and instead could reduce the cost of a
trip a hundred fold in 2015 both blue
origin and SpaceX successfully landed
rockets touchdown engine stopped Musk's
reaction welcome back baby now here's
the argument since the space shuttle
program ended at 2011 nASA has been
focused on Mars and the farther reaches
of space that leaves Russia's siyou
spacecraft as NASA's only option for
sending astronauts into orbit rides that
cost around 70 million dollars per seat
some argue that private competition will
bring down the price and with it the
cost of space exploration but there are
very real safety concerns virgin
galactic's spaceshiptwo designed to halt
tourists to the edge of space crash on a
test flight in october 2014 killing a
pilot but for a commercial company in
addition to being a tragedy a crash with
passengers on board could and space
tourism all together for now NASA's only
option seems to be Russia